une attaque à l arme blanche contre des
policiers cela s'est passé ce matin
devant le commissariat central de cannes
dans les alpes maritimes
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est rendu
sur place on retrouve notre reporter
nadège ad razak place beauvau boussouar
nadège que deal enquête ce soir sur
cette attaque et sur l'assaillant
écoutez stéphanie l'attaqué on le
rappelle a eu a eu lieu très tôt ce
matin aux alentours de 6h30 vous l'avez
dit devant le commissariat central de
cannes alors un individu a ouvert la
porte d'un véhicule de police et a
asséné un coup de couteau au niveau du
thorax du conducteur le un autre
policier a alors riposté il a fait usage
de son arme à feu pour et bien venir en
aide à son collègue le secrétaire
départemental du syndicat unité sgp
police fo nous en dit plus sur les
circonstances de cette agression
tout se passe en 12 secondes c'est
rapide 1 12 secondes à ça ça va très
très vite et c'est là qu'on voit vous
savez moi il ya 26 ans que je fais ce
métier là donc ça fait un petit moment
et c'est là qu'on se dit que les
collègues qui notamment sorte d'école
sont pas te patent aguerris et si on
n'est pas guéri à apprendre des coups de
couteau dans tous les cas ils ont eu un
véritable réflexe qui est salvateur
parce que ce réflexe qui consiste dans
un temps record à sortir du véhicule et
à neutraliser un individu qui est en
train de planter un collègue ça va très
très vite je vous prie de croire que ça
va très vite et ils ont eu vraiment un
réflexe extraordinaire en ce qui
concerne l'assaillant il a rapidement
été neutralisée touché par balle à trois
reprises son pronostic vital est engagé
il est actuellement entre la vie et la
mort ans hospitalisé à cannes gérald
darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur
s'est rapidement rendue sur place il
nous en dit plus sur le profil de
l'assaillant
à ma connaissance d'un seyant était
régulièrement sur le territoire national
je veux redire qu'il avait un passeport
algérien rentrait sur le continent
européen voilà manifestement plus de dix
ans rentrait en france normalement dans
les années 2016 et il avait demandé
puisqu'il y avait un titre de séjour
italien il avait demandé à voir un titre
de séjour français qui pour l'instant ne
lui avait pas été donnée par les
services de la préfecture mais il était
régulièrement sur le tas et en national
ça monsieur qui travaillait qui a
manifestement entre 35 et 40 ans et qui
était encore une fois en règle sur le
territoire national il n'avait à ma
connaissance aucun casier judiciaire
n'était donc pas connu des services de
police selon les informations que j'ai
au moment où je vous parle et ils
n'étaient inscrits dont aucun des
fichiers de radicalisation
l'enquète
l'enquète ça a été confiée à la police
judiciaire de nice qui va tenter
d'apporter des précisions sur
l'agresseur et surtout sur ses
motivations alors le parquet anti le
parquet national anti terroriste n'a pas
encore été saisie de l'enquêté mais elle
à la piste terroriste n'est pour l'heure
pas totalement écartée merci natacha
abderrazak en direct donc de la place
beauvau